[Music]
one boy ten girls wouldn't trade it for
the world
not even all the worlds that were
referenced in this wacky show stay tuned
to hear how the loud house took some
inspiration for some of the most iconic
movies ever don't forget to subscribe to
the things and give this video a big
thumbs up now let's check out ten
unexpected references you missed in the
loud house SuperMario there are some
pretty well hidden Super Mario
references in the loud house fans have
compared Lola to peach and wondered if
there's a connection between the two
since the characters are very similar in
their looks the reference hasn't been
confirmed however you can clearly see
some resemblance right but that's not an
official shout-out in the episode called
a butterfly effect you can see ELISA
wearing a red cap the cap actually looks
very similar to the Super Mario cap the
same color the same shade this is
definitely not a coincidence but wait
there's more in the episode called poke
friction
luan made a move that was actually
pretty similar to something you'd see in
the Mario Kart series these references
are so subtle you'd never even realize
they're there so in poke friction Lin
throws a boomerang at the principal's
golf cart as they're trying to catch up
to him and then luan throws a banana
peel in front of him once the golf cart
goes over the banana peel it starts
swerving until it eventually spins out
doesn't that sound like exactly what
happens in Mario Kart seems like it's
not a coincidence that all the Super
Mario connections exist in the loud
house too right ac/dc the musical
references in the loud house are
absolutely insane but we've got many
kids these days don't even know who
ac/dc are well we hope their legacy
carried on through the rock chick that
is Luna loud but we're here to point out
these references just in case you didn't
know what they're about Luna made plenty
of references to ac/dc songs but they
were cleverly masked as one-liners for
example in no guts no glory she directly
quoted the song for those about to rock
and in butterfly effect
she said she uploaded a song about the
loud family going down a certain highway
that goes to a place down below we'd say
it but a certain challenge taught us
it's a bad word the last word was masked
by hello as she realized she got 50 more
hits on her song it's a pretty
straightforward reference to one of
ac/dc s most popular songs for those
about to rock is
again as it referenced in the actual
title for four bros about to rock as
well as said by the mall cop captain the
reference to for those about to rock
continues throughout the show which is a
pretty awesome tribute to ac/dc other
music references but it's not just ac/dc
that managed to be highlighted in the
loud house even though they did have the
most features Luna pays a tribute to
plenty of iconic rock bands she does
this through songs but the loud house is
also known for using references in their
titles almost every episode title is a
nod to either something related to music
or movies but we'll talk about the
movies a bit later moon is one liners
include lyrics from Drake Aerosmith Pink
Floyd Aretha Franklin delivery Cyrus and
even Britney Spears her character really
embraces the fact that she is a rock
chick and hey it worked it's safe to say
that if you have no idea about
old-school rock music none of these
artists might make sense to you but we
do hope Luna's Rock obsession still made
you check out some of these iconic
artists Luna's one-liners are usually
straight to the point with lyrics
directly taken out of the songs but
sometimes they get creatively masked
which makes the whole situation even
funnier like when she referenced the
mustang sally' song and added Ride Sally
Ride after saying she had to do some
work on it we seriously can't get enough
of Luna peanuts over the years several
Nickelodeon shows paid a tribute to the
one and only peanuts and the loud house
was no difference the loud house
actually has made hidden peanuts
references you'd never really noticed
unless you know where to look we already
exposed some of the big ones but did you
know that Lincoln's dog is called
Charles named after Charles M Schulz the
creator of peanuts comic books and
whenever it's winter Lincoln actually
wears outfits that actually resembles
something you'd see Charlie Brown where
you can also find several background
moments that indicate as peanuts shout
out like the time you could see two
shirts resembling Charlie Brown's shirt
in the background of a clothes store in
two boys and a baby you can see Lincoln
zoo fives dance from a Charlie Brown
Christmas and that's not even all of the
references these tributes are so subtle
that there's no way most people would
notice them unless you pay attention to
detail but it totally makes sense that
one of the best Nickelodeon shows ever
would be inspired by one of the best
comic books ever seriously if you re
watch the episodes for pretty sure you
can catch at least a dozen references
really hidden in the background hey
Arnold one of our favorite references on
this show are the very subtle Hey Arnold
references if you think about it
modern kids these days don't really know
old school shows like peanuts or hey
Arnold
so paint a tribute to them is really
aimed at adults who watch this show
everyone wants pleasantly surprised when
they realize at the pool scene in link
or swim features a familiar character at
some point you can see grandpa Phil in
the bottom right corner it's such a
subtle reference that you definitely
wouldn't notice unless you know the Hey
Arnold characters this reference
actually makes sense since Chris Savino
also worked on hey Arnold but unless you
pause the episode at the right time it's
something you wouldn't normally pay
attention to speaking of the pool scene
has so many surprising references so you
should definitely pause it to see how
many you recognize we can tell you right
now that you can find references to at
least five other elderly cartoon
characters in a single shot seriously
we're totally amazed by all these
shoutouts to some of our favorite
characters shows and artists of the pop
culture but the loud house also pay
homage to other icons Shakespeare now
here's something kids these days
definitely would notice when you think
of Shakespeare you probably think of the
famous to be or not to be quote but
there was so much more to this amazing
writer in fact you can find several very
subtle Shakespeare quotes in our
favorite Nickelodeon show the loud house
made a reference to Shakespeare on two
separate occasions the first time was in
the episode called spell it out where we
see Lucy use a spell book to teach her
siblings a lesson because she's annoyed
at them we've all been there Lucy but
did you notice the spell she's been
using she says things like lizards leg
and owlets wing which is directly taken
from Macbeth's act for what a cool
shout-out and if you've been watching
season 3 you can also find a Shakespeare
reference in the episode called white
hair we see Warren the rabbit read
rabbit version of Shakespeare called
shakes hare this of course is a play on
Shakespeare and well rabbits who would
have thought that Shakespeare's work
would have such influence even more than
400 years after his publications and
Lucy is just the perfect character to
pay homage to this iconic writer
spongebob the shout outs to spongebob
have probably been the most obvious in
the loud house but one of them gets
frequently missed season 1 episode 1 of
the lob house already starts with the
bang but you might want to rewatch it
because while you were focusing
the characters themselves and trying to
get to know them a lot of things happen
in the background this very subtle
reference occurs for a split second so
it's very easily missed it happens right
in the first scene of the first episode
where Lincoln explains that every Sunday
at 8 o'clock allowed siblings go through
the exact same thing
aka they're fighting for that remote
because they all want to watch a
different show we have no idea who chose
that channel but you can actually see a
yellow square character and a pink star
character on the screen they disappear
before you can even say wait what but
we're pretty sure this is a reference to
SpongeBob and Patrick of course the loud
house version of them is much more
simple but it would be a crazy
coincidence if this wasn't planned since
the loud house actually beat spongebob
in ratings it's nice to see this humble
shout out Futurama
the loud house really got inspired by a
lot of things didn't it
but hold on we're not done yet this
strange and kind of obscure reference
can be found in season 2 episode 16
again this is so subtle that unless year
of Futurama fan you'd probably never
even notice it even though the object
itself really stood out at the beginning
of the episode Lisa proposes to put
Luanne in a freezing chamber to avoid
her for April Fool's Day seriously
though even though Lisa is incredibly
smart she might have went slightly
overboard with this crazy idea freezing
your sister on April Fool's come on now
Luanne is known as the prankster of the
family and it seems that everyone has
had enough of it
can't blame them really sometimes you
just want a break from the pranks but
did you notice that the freezing chamber
looks strangely similar to the cryogenic
tubes you see in a series pilot of
Futurama sure it could be a coincidence
but it's just way too similar in the way
it looks there haven't been any other
noticeable Futurama references on the
show yet but we're keeping our eyes
peeled because we're pretty sure that
we'll be seeing more Futurama episodes
in the future movies it's not just music
that's frequently referenced on the loud
house movies have frequently been
referenced on the show have you pay
attention to the title cards you'll
notice that almost every episode title
is a pun and a reference to a popular
movie for example Driving Miss Daisy is
a clear reference to the 90s movie
called Driving Miss Daisy you can also
find some pretty direct references such
as the episode titled butterfly effect
along Camus sister is a shout-out to the
2004 movie Along Came Polly and
it's not a movie the infamous series
toddlers in tiaras also made it on the
loud house a play on words - the episode
called
codes in tiaras it's not clear whether
the episodes were named after the movies
that influenced Chris savino's work or
whether Chris just thought they deserve
a shout-out seriously check the episode
titles and we bet you can find that they
relate to plenty of movies like the two
boys in a baby episode which is a
reference to the popular movie called
three men and a baby these references
really never stop so next time you watch
the loud house make sure to pay special
attention to the hidden meanings of each
episode title ctrl + Alt + sweets now
this is a reference you'd absolutely
never expect as most people have
probably never heard of it unless you're
a huge comic book fan ctrl + Alt +
delete is a gaming related webcomic
which focuses on The Adventures of Ethan
a video game fanatic but a particular of
ctrl + Alt + the leaves storyline called
loss became one of the longest-running
memes in the internet world and the loud
house seems to have wanted to give it a
shout-out The Lost scene itself talks
about miscarriage and for some strange
reason the comic found its way into the
world of internet memes we won't go into
too much detail but have you managed to
see the exact lost story in Luann's room
pay close attention to the poster in the
top right corner it's a four panel
poster with different scenes in each
panel but if you compare it to the
original lost scene you'll notice that
the stick figures are placed in the same
way as characters from ctrl + Alt +
delete since Chris Savino did say he
always wanted to make a comic strip it's
safe to say he's inspired by this
popular and strange mean it really makes
you wonder what houses in Luann's room
that you've never noticed before doesn't
it and that's all for our video thanks
for watching see you next time
[Music]